[Music]
anybody here uh
jlo or ben affleck fans
right there man
i'm a huge benefer like you're bedford
20 years in the making type stuff i
follow the reddit thread it's [ __ ]
really good are you [ __ ] lying right
now no no they show all their paparazzi
pics wherever they go out to eat so i'm
always following like where they are in
la you know can i tell you some hot
spots
i never thought j.lo was hot in junior
high immediate high school kind of me
neither college or anything right
and then now i'm like damn she's really
hot when she's like 50 something
cause it's insanely impressive yeah i
never thought she i thought she was like
oh whatever she's pretty but she's not
like
like
yeah my tongue's not rolling out on the
table yeah yeah you're not slamming
oh come to daddy come on
maybe that's the age the age group that
you you enjoy you're like like a 50 year
old maybe you're looking at your
hispanic wife and you're thinking about
other things i know maybe but when you
see jayla she don't look like regular 30
year olds you know what i mean like she
looks like she's just hot she's the
george clooney of ladies i think she's
like clooney she looks like a latin
death becomes her
you know that movie no no one's seen
that no dude no sorry yeah yeah we did
you didn't give us our movie watch a
movie called latin death become sir oh
she's a latin version of death becomes
right
i was like latin death becomes an
interesting title
well um they have uh gotten married
again
i thought they got married and got
divorced but they're married before
isn't this third yeah this is the third
time no
well he's the benefit fan this is the
second time so what's your [ __ ] mouth
[Laughter]
they're already in production for g lee
too so oh no
no
there's a second marriage or the this is
the third right i'm the authority so
yeah it's the second it's the second
it's jlo's eighth marriage though they
thought it was like uh just to promote
the movie remember
foreign and then they like divorced and
then it was over now they're
here it is so their first marriage was
actually fake no everyone was like that
was what the tabloid take was because
they like had a romance and then a movie
came out with both of them co-starring
uh so that was like a conspiracy
marketing conspiracy do you think they
kind of had their rounds with people and
realized i'm not gonna get any better
than this for sure and then they both
were like we made a mistake i feel like
they very explicitly went out and made
some rounds i think it's his theory
where they're gonna just have another
movie they're gonna do another movie
this is what it is yeah this is it's the
build-up if they do there's something
kind of like damn that's [ __ ] alpha
of them dude that's like way crazy i'm
into it i'm a big fan of that because
i'm insane yeah they're like just uh
we're gonna rope the media and all of
the population of the earth hey that's
a-list marketing though
when you're a-list actors you have to
have some kind of like personal thing to
yeah as long as you don't care about the
integrity and sanctity of like marriage
and union under god they're the best
influencers is it just me or do i see or
do you guys also see
them as
ben lopez rather than jennifer affleck
whoa watch your [ __ ] mouth dude
man dude it is ben lopez ben lopez
jennifer
obviously did more stuff she's jenny
from the block you know what i mean it's
bruce lopez it's bruce lopez
jennifer wayne
jennifer it's ben lopez it's not
jennifer he's definitely like the boss
of bosses man she is she overshadows him
she ran up a-rod dude you know what i
mean she was
a-rod was
alex lopez
hey how did how did they how did they
end or why did they end again do you
know cheating was it
oh he he cheated he cheated on her
cheated jlo didn't do no wrong and all
that jayla's a [ __ ] saint okay
jayla's loki a [ __ ]
she was the maid in manhattan she's
low-key of this yeah she's kind of
annoying an actual direct experience
with jayla well you don't like confident
women is that what it is are you saying
she doesn't she's she's [ __ ] boss
she's super hot when she walks into a
room everyone shuts the [ __ ] up myself
included like your dick just rolls up
into your in between your legs and
you're like i didn't realize that this
level of boss existed she has that kind
of energy she has that energy literally
like i remember the moment where she
[ __ ] we came in we're just shooting a
small package for nbc right yeah
she's got a hoop earring that just keeps
falling
right it just like falls off and is that
clumsy those are heavy hoops it's like
lady one of the one of the makeup people
just like trying to desperately put it
back on right like we start rolling
again falls off again and she like she
gets really pissed in a way that it
wasn't like yells but it was like
everyone felt like they were going to
die you know what i mean they could feel
her frustration yeah you can feel the
frustration i was like damn this is some
powerful [ __ ] i've never seen in my life
dictator moves yeah that's like this
[ __ ] guy kind of a dictator she is
but it was hot it was very hot yeah it
was very very funny so she was a judge
right yeah she was just she put on a
kid's jacket she didn't sell her butt
was amazing like just like you [ __ ]
see in the towel wait which show was
this nbc world of dance world of dance
but then when we get to the actual
judging part
when you know and again just being like
a young naive actually want to be
artists you know you you want the
idealism to kind of kick in in the
moments of like
yeah i don't know it's a dance
competition you're hoping some element
of the dance contest comes in more than
just good tv
it's all entertainment bro yeah it's all
entertaining you can see cause it's
never in the cuts and stuff you could
see her you know like neo and [ __ ]
derek huff are like arguing with her
about like you know keoni and mari
should have [ __ ] won the round i'll
say this i don't give a [ __ ] yeah say it
but you might lose twice man neo and
[ __ ] derek are like over they're
standing up in the judges because she's
in the middle because she executive
producers they're like trying to argue
that she's sitting there she's just like
whoa
everyone in the [ __ ] show knew that
they should have won you know what i
mean nothing guess what twins the twins
are [ __ ] amazing but in that moment
of competition in kyoto kenya mari
should have for sure won and you just
see her just like making this
it very much so felt like a preconceived
tv call that made sense to like you know
if you're going to have certain winners
did she have a production like was she
she's the ep yeah so if you're ep you
overwrite everything exactly so i get it
it was just one of those things where
it's like jenny from the block you were
like kind of my heartthrob hero yeah and
now i'm like oh you're just like a
regular ep you know what i mean you're
like you got to do what you got to do to
win
did the ep smell good i bet she smells
good i don't think we were allowed to
get close enough you didn't get close
enough i hugged her a little bit
but she wore
whose jacket did she wear no we gave her
one oh it was it was a new one
it was a new one
what's your guys's favorite jayla movie
let's go around the room
starting with you ryan
what is it enough is that her that's a
good one where is that that oh she's a
fighter
she looks at a box and it beats up her
[ __ ] abusive husband caught actually
fire that one was she an anaconda she
was an anaconda
oh she was that was fire bro anaconda
yo what was that music video where she
like goes up to the
audition and [ __ ]
does sexual [ __ ] on the table
hustler
was it no no no oh that was a good movie
actually i talked about coyote ugly
there's a music video i think it was a
music video where she comes up
she comes up to like a like an audition
yeah and then she does some sexy [ __ ] on
the table that's gone girl in front of
it
it's it's definitely ben lopez right now
the way we're talking about this it's
definitely ben lopez
that's the town the town
a long time ago i think she showed us
like a vmas or some [ __ ] and she's
wearing this really skimpy like green
dress like this iconic oh dude iconic
yeah i remember this on vietnamese radio
that like people were saying [ __ ] so my
mom suddenly comes in the [ __ ] room
right she's talking about it's like you
shouldn't be watching that and i'm not
even watching at the moment i'm really
not even watching the shoes just like
you hear about this you shouldn't watch
it's too sexy like why the [ __ ] would
you say i immediately googled it like
you know it wasn't even google's like
aol at the time yeah i'm immediately
looking it up because my mom's saying
it's too sexy to look at the kitchen
look at it i'm like why the [ __ ] would
you say that start jack it's gonna make
me wanna go look at it yeah and then the
south park guys showed up to a award
show in the same dress oh they did it
was the same dress they parker did
anything
yeah they didn't show up in ben lopez's
outfit am i right who the [ __ ] is that
guy
our favorite ben affleck movie go
where he where he's the lead i do like
the town i'm a fan of the town that was
that was fun
that was fun argo is pretty great argo's
good actually is really good yeah argo
is going to direct that too right i
think my favorite movie with jennifer
lopez in is a money train
money truck wesley snipes oh
dude i haven't thought about that movie
forever dave she's been in a lot of
shows
everything woody harrelson
their best buddies are black and white
but they're best buddies remember black
and white and then and then woody keeps
getting his ass beat and a white man
can't jump yeah no but featuring jayla
wait did wasn't that oh no that's not
wesley snipes wait was that that wasn't
that was yeah oh wait
yeah but yeah those who are the same
actors then yeah okay rosie perez in
place of jlo yeah that's rosie perez
yeah yeah that's right andy i feel like
you've been pretty quiet about the jlo
stuff sounds like you don't really it
sounds like you don't have an opinion on
jlo which one did you jack off to ben
affleck or jayla
affleck
the batman suit come on dude you got the
[ __ ] bills fellas honestly is such a
shitty batman here's a hot take all
right look how tech if
selena was still alive do you think
jayla would have ever made it
because she kind of replaced she played
selena yeah that's true that's true she
was replaced that's my favorite jlo
movie selena dude that's a good one
actually that's a good act it's not even
about her when i saw it when i was a kid
in the theater and i cried afterwards
when i found out she got shot you what
crime spoiler alert dude
as a child i was a kid my mom took me to
go see selena
hey she gets right and i was like i love
this movie what's that young what's that
young girl uh who's uh a singer right
now is really popular very very avril
lavigne uh pop
olivia roberto rodrigo or something
maybe she'll play jlo when jayla gets
like murdered she's just filipino
i'm just saying they're a-list marketers
maybe jayla like officers she's like
she's super she's too late she's
filipino she's she can't play jayla she
has to play pilo
now you know they got that androgynous
ambiguous kind of racial thing going on
you know what i'm saying like as long as
you filipinos are one of a kind
colonialized by hispanic culture you can
play them you know what i mean right
rodrigo kind of works right
maybe ariana grande should gain like 30
pounds true
she came through yeah because she's tiny
i'm a fan of her music by the way too
you guys listen to ariana grande album
yeah i actually think she has good music
yeah she's pretty good
very good pretty good she's very it's
for pop music right now she's she's the
queen you know i think it's pretty good
she'd be like you know she was she's
still a big sean no no
big shout out him in a janae i ain't go
just posted on her that's right janae
that's the guy it was a big sean it was
it was uh it was janae i [ __ ] with
janae aiko yeah oh yeah who doesn't not
her forehead too greasy
every time
every time i see her you can see a
reflection she needs [ __ ] them
[ __ ] clear cell patches or some [ __ ]
dude it's glossy i'm not gonna argue
greasy foreheads yeah yeah so would you
rather jack off to ben affleck
[Music]
you